in that moment I did not think it was a
terrorist attack
in that moment I didn't think it was
anything out of the ordinary until I saw
the guns and then I thought this is
something different yeah and after that
Dave what did you then see well I don't
want to use this isms of political
football the police were incredible they
were competent they were highly skilled
and incredibly good at dealing with the
situation after that I was on the phone
to the paramedics for over half an hour
the police said liaised with me and said
that they were trying to call the
paramedics as well while unfortunately a
innocent man perhaps more lay on the
street bleeding out before anybody
arrived and the police shared my
frustration that nobody was there even
though we were less than a mile away
from two of the biggest hospitals and
learned - one of them with an acute
trauma unit and to be honest at that
point in time my only concern was the
poor person I had seen on the street
that was bleeding out in a pool of their
own blood I didn't know any more than
that but I think anybody in that
situation would see someone that is in
dire need of medical attention that is
your prime objective is to make sure
that person is okay so you were tending
to one of the injured today so I was
standing there and I was running back
and forth there were three people from
three members of the public that were
there they were using my blanket to
suppress the wound one person I think
seemed to know and had medical knowledge
and sent me off to the crossroads in
order to flag down the ambulance so I
ran to the crossroads and then after
about 10 minutes I ran back thinking
that the ambulance must have arrived and
I was sent back and I kept on checking
in I also luckily saw one of my friend
- is part of the military and asked him
if he'd got his Medicare on it in order
to attend the scene by this point this
is really before there was any police
cordon and that's not to say the police
and do their job whatsoever it was just
an incredibly frantic situation
you